[Musique]
ur a changé
il y à 2 608 milles que chara paris dont
20% de femmes l'autoroute des berges les
achats ses dépens le marché de rungis
les a fait disparaître des halles ils
ont perdu le gîte et le couvert alors il
bricole
[Musique]
ah ça fait du vélo
on valoir
motif
et l air tout famille
karine
c'est la jolie
les gens comprennent
[Musique]
je
alors c'est tout c'est ainsi qu'en
balagne
[Musique]
ça va l'appétit l'un des compagnons
smith et ça c'est l'heure du
casse-croûte suisse et le moment est ce
que vous faites vous fait les papiers
aux ravages se déclare comme on l a
porté sur
vous lever tôt pour sa part à 2050 matin
à 5 heures du matin à tard si vous
arrivez trop tard après les vous étiez
au pensionnat curieux ou bien vous
gagnez avec sarah n'arrive à faire 2000
francs par mois
soit moins deux fois plus ça dépend des
jours ça vaut combien le kilo savent
aussi franchi le siphon kg à sa faveur
qu'il pourrait pas pourquoi on ferait
pas sens ce sentiment s'est passé nous
[Applaudissements]
moi je faisais la literie la tapisserie
vous voyez dans le probablement quoi
alors il voit après cela bas en bretagne
j'ai fait d'actes a tué par un douze
anges teinturier mais comment vous êtes
passé à un métier
si vous ajoutez à cela c'est à dire que
moi quand je t'ai l'accident le mon pied
j'ai eu pied cassé et alors j'étais
l'hôpital pendant deux mois et quand je
suis sorti de l'hôpital gp retrouvez le
travail alors se pressera d'agrément
pour manger quoi tout ensemble tous les
deux là
vous avez à domicile non voyez vous il
ya une chose qui existe c'est que entre
camarades de misère comme un t1 on
s'entend très bien si l'huile un bout de
pain ils me donnent le métier est seemo
journée ont fait passer par m quel
travail ou face grands musiciens
acrobates et danseurs
moi j'étais moteurs seront sur la jante
rage et après
je me suis comme les poignets
transmettez 36 misère je te les joueurs
dans la gendarmerie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici la délivrance
croyez qu enfin la puissance
de notre
modérateur
vide greniers dégoupillant
année allait lui le vainqueur
avant de nouvelles de cette dernière
la route est passé à vide elle vous
conduira par la main ne s'allient pour
tout ce que je suis grâce aux atouts
s'est offert à tous ces données romney
pêcheurs
les wampas et vous serez pardonner tous
à la cour et dans la prière et demander
la bénédiction du seigneur sur cette
réunion oui notre dieu nous te demandons
aussi
de pouvoir seigneur alors une nourriture
de chaque jour tu as dit
demander le pain quotidien
[Musique]
moi si vous avez couché maintenant un
d'or où ça un peu partout on peut
trouver un abri toute façon j'en ai un
abri
où on peut trouver un abri quoi
ça
soit sur une bouche de métro en dessous
un pont dans des maisons en démolition
[Musique]
obligés parce que quand on trouve une
tasse on est bridée par la police après
les bleus là qui nous emmène à nanterre
les bleus appelés ainsi à cause de leur
tenue ce sont des spécialistes de la
préfecture de police chargée de ramasser
les clochards et les conduire près de
paris à l'hospice de nanterre
[Musique]
à
foyer soleil
lambert
et et rendez vous raté
[Musique]
à papiers d'identité
ce qu'elle vous pouvez justifier de
votre domicile et pas de travail non
monsieur alors ni des autres pas plus
mais une goutte cep en 2008
[Musique]
voilà
but à domicile
moi
alors bien sûr
si vous faites un métier fait le
trottoir
fait voir aux papiers philippe sont dit
oui aucun vous êtes contrôlés
régulièrement monsieur
sens large
[Musique]
o
o arlidge que le car mais
prenez votre sac et soyez polis
bon selon l'air aux affaires madame sous
peu
vous prendrez votre avenir
année
[Musique]
il
lui non
attention bien carte d'identité
prénom du père et bellecour diminué par
ailleurs valrhona
regard
vous remettez intérieur là
je sais comment le monde
et être plus rien sous l'ère blanc je
n'ai cru
j'avais de l'argent
le fait sentir je n'avais plus que ça
avait 11 centimes
la ceinture
le 20 mai
dias situe encore des objets lattes une
paire de lunettes
la ceinture
[Musique]
m
nous
[Musique]
au mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le disent ils
bon j'ai beaucoup de monde
[Musique]
et
gbagbo
[Musique]
sur l'est
ils peuvent repartir de nanterre tout de
suite s'ils veulent ou choisir d'y
passer l'hiver à l'abri sans prendre
d'autres risques que celui d'une
certaine sanctions lorsqu'ils ont un peu
trop abusé de leur liberté du dimanche
dans les cafés voisins
et
ils en sortiront aux premiers beaux
jours
où un petit matin
avec trois fleurs achetées par les
voisins dortoir
[Musique]